my name is in Chile I'm a graduate
student in Kinshasa in the McGovern
Institute for brain research and Broad
Institute a neuroscience research we're
kind of navigating without a map right
now the system neuroscience probe the
brain by means of electrical recording
local manipulation it's pretty much like
you take a probe you go into the
electric circuit without the circuit
diagram and you probe like point by
point and there try to figure out how it
works that's really difficult but the
ones we have the connectome is like you
have the circuit diagram so connecthome
is about the connectivity of neurons and
how they are wired up together people
has a long-term interesting connector
since 1970s
that's a time when people apply electron
microscope techniques to stand worm
nerve systems it took almost ten years
to be able to finish that it's only
involved 300 euros and when we go up to
mammalian brains let's say Mouse you
know a millimeter cubic there are
thousand neurons and maybe billions of
synapses connections and how our way
figure out they're wearing their ground
it's gonna take us years and years to
finish so my research involves a new
approach to tackle the connection
problem that is by sequencing right now
people can do sequencing billions of
nucleotides in a few hours actually so
if we can convert the connection problem
to a problem of sequencing then we can
solve them probably a much timely manner
and a cheaper way but my research team
from grants lab involves primarily three
parts so the first part is to be able to
individually label neurons where is a
barcode with a called barcode is a
unique nucleotide sequences and so once
we label individual neurons then we have
to associate their connection with those
barcodes and that's we call labeling the
connections or synapses and the third
part of research is to be able to
retrieve those connected associated
barkos
that represents the synaptic connection
and at the same time we can look at what
are the neuronal identity genes being
associated with that particular barcode
we'll be able to tell what kind of
neuron tag we're looking at my career
goal is to really solve the connectome
this may take decades but you know I'm
really interested in this it will
revolutionize potentially the way then
system you know science ask questions
and curing your own diseases